lee zeldin is a member of congress from
new york eastern long island he's
running for governor of the state
against the unelected incumbent now last
night a man called david jacob bonus
attempted to stab zeldan during a
campaign event he charged the stage with
a blade here's footage of the attack
there's only one option
[Music]
so how did this guy know where zeldan
was well days before the attack kathy
hokel once again who was the governor
but has not been elected governor sent
out an email listing zeldin's upcoming
campaign appearances and telling her
supporters he's an extremist now if lee
zeldin's an extremist then we're all in
trouble she also tweeted that zelda is
quote dangerous for new york not just
wrong but dangerous what a nut case she
is that's the lady with the vaccinated
necklace
after the attack lee zeldin predicted
that the man who tried to stab him would
get out of jail quickly thanks to new
york's bail laws and that is of course
exactly what happened the attacker was
released from jail with no bail of any
kind now you just saw in the tape that
he was tackled and joe chenelli is the
man who did it he's executive director
of american veterans he joins us tonight
joe thanks so much for coming on and
bless you for what you did you didn't
hesitate at all
tell us the circumstance how did you you
seem to have keyed in on this guy right
away
how
yes
so thanks for having me on tucker um so
i was the master of ceremonies of the
rally last night i'm also running for
new york state assembly in that area in
fairport
and about about five minutes before the
incident i noticed a gentleman walking
into the rally kind of staggering
and it just he didn't seem right it was
really high energy
very positive atmosphere large crowd and
when he came in just didn't seem to have
the same vibe
and i took notice of that i was standing
just off stage saw him walk up to the
edge of the side of the stage where
several other people were he stood there
was watching i continued to watch him a
little bit as i was continuing to watch
the congressman as well and then he
jumped up onto the stage
i couldn't get to where he was at that
time so i ran around behind the stage
came up behind the congressman as i
didn't know exactly what this uh guy's
intentions were as he walked up
uh i watched him and he walked directly
up to the congressman uh as your viewers
just saw uh told the congressman that
you're done and then he pulled a weapon
that was attached to his hand and he
swung at
congressman zeldin's face or his throat
area congressman zelda was able to block
that strike or attempted strike and hold
his wrist
as he pulled his wrist back to try to uh
swing again i grabbed him from behind
was able to bear hug him and slam him
down to the ground where were able to uh
eventually get his weapon away from him
and restrain him until the law
enforcement came
amazing
have you ever been a cop how do you how
do you have such high situational
awareness
um no i was a marine for seven years
active duty i've been to iraq and
afghanistan oh some of those instincts
kicked in um
as well and just
was really blessed to be around some
really uh fast-reacting people
amen i'm so glad you were there
impressive joe gently thank you very
much for coming on good luck in your
race
thank you tucker i appreciate it
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight